here's another question okay hey
everyone my name is ma bed and I need my
bed first name P and I'm 18 from London
for my whole life my dad has been this
dark cloud over my life and anytime I
see or think of him
it brings me anxiety and depression he
is from Bangladesh and I was raised in
London so I understand there is a
cultural difference however as a child
nearly every day I watched him
emotionally and physically abused my
mother my mother is a reserved British
Bengali woman and after twelve years of
an abusive marriage she finally built up
the courage to leave him I was never
more happy but that wasn't the end he
used regularly he would regularly show
up at her house and get into yelling
matches with my mom which would
inevitably end up with my mom get
getting hurt badly I felt so weak and
small as a kid because I couldn't do
anything to stop him on top of this the
Bengali community is a very judgment is
very judgmental about divorces meaning a
lot of people broke ties with my mother
and she was left a broken woman my mom
didn't inform police about any of the
abuse so he could keep his job as a
teacher which therefore meant he was
allowed to take my sister and I every
weekend now at the age of 18 I am still
scared of him and I am a wimp of a man I
regularly get emotionally abused and
also physically hit by him for not
getting good grades or not doing
something his way in my culture I am
expected to get a good job and give all
my money to my parents which really D
motivates me he tells me he has the
worst luck in the world because he ended
up with a son like me I hate everything
about my life and I can't see any
happiness in my future with him in my
life let me see what can I do to deal
with something with someone like this
just edit it down
I thought that was a very okay sorry I
couldn't paraphrase the rest because
it's like I tuned out out to the first
day you know it's fine
anyway Bangladesh what you do what no
let me say you go your turn I did the
bottle whole no with my point of view is
this is is that you know my parents were
the same right
very traditional Korean my dad beat the
[ __ ] out of my brother and I with
baseball bats and golf clubs right and
to blood blood coming out of my mom my
her mouth missing teeth my dad was a
very violent and then when I you know
graduate from high school you look to go
to college it all that stuff right and I
was just like dad I got all Epson I said
what the [ __ ] what the rehabs I can't go
nowhere right he's trying to take over
the business
I go [ __ ] it [ __ ] you right and I'm
gonna make it as a comedian artist okay
and I did everything I could I used that
him right to motivate me to get out of
you know the situation that I was in I
came to LA with nothing wouldn't you
know and I you know I built somewhat
fine okay career you know and I but if
you're living under his house like let's
say a little later I would have [ __ ]
like did you even hear him yeah but you
know what dude it's like at one point
you at some point you have to go I'm not
current I am Korean you know my blood
you know and my ethnicity but in terms
of cultural I'm not I mean it really
even American I'm just my own thing you
know
I'm just a weird dude right but I do
know this is is that I need I can't I
don't like stress and I don't like that
feeling of like you know I get depressed
easy I have to do what I didn't want to
do and for this guy I think he just
needs to [ __ ] cut the chains and fly
yeah so had Harley how old is he 18
yeah he has to get out and he has to
forgive
have you ever forgiven your dad is he
still alive
yeah you never forgiven him yes stroke
bro you did yeah
have you ever forgiven him yeah I
completely forgive my dad I I went to
hear the stroke you know my brother and
I were both looking at him were both
crying because he was in the hospital
and he couldn't talk he was going like
that like you know right and we were
both on our knees crying this is you
know four or five years ago and I at
that moment I said I just all that good
you know I mean just went away I love my
dad I love my mom you know and but you
know did I love him in my 20s not really
not a lot to love it sounds like yeah
but you know I found it and when when I
start got on my hand you know and he
apologized eventually he said um I'm
sorry I I didn't think that you could do
it and you did it you know and I went I
spit on his face you see did you [ __ ]
urine in his mouth I'm sorry to hear
your dad out of stroke tough guys had
forgiveness why cuz that's the only way
you could forgive your dad forgive
everybody for everything yeah you do
mm-hmm
did you have a rough one no I had a
great I had a great great parents yeah
but I had to forgive them for certain
things that you know every kid has
things they feel were unjust or weren't
born right or good so but this this
child or this boy this 18 year old needs
to forgive his father even though it's
brutal and he just has to walk away he
has to move out of that take himself out
of that environment but he can't leave
if he's carrying all that anger because
it'll be on his back like a piano so
just to look I mean he can't change his
dad it's all he can do is look him in
the eye
say I love you I forgive you goodbye and
then he can walk away as a whole person
and and his father will have to stay
with what he's created yeah and that's
it but that's important
I'm glad you had that moment with your
dad it's good it's beautiful the
forgiveness you forgave him yeah but he
forgave you it's okay that's nice if
it's okay I don't know what you're doing
it's good yeah but honestly I don't know
what you're doing you really are you're
acting like you're [ __ ] Elvis [ __ ]
lips or like going crazy waves on me
right yeah like that and you're like
look at me with your little glassy and
your do it you keep repeating it right
it gets to the point where you're
challenging me all right give you for
that what stop [ __ ] you know I don't
forgive you [ __ ] you you for what you
know what dude you know what dude
I'm gonna let this go all right I'm
gonna pretend this never happened all
right forget the forgiving too late
playa you already did it
it's already done I already forgave you
yeah all right we are buddy and divided
for sure okay you have anything to
promote [ __ ]
[Music]